Traduttore: Ana Birsa
Revisore: ila S.
Nell'87 avevo nove anni,
una nuova famiglia,
e sperimentavo, per la prima volta,
la vita in campeggio.
Eravamo in Toscana
e anche all'epoca
si organizzavano attività
rivolte esclusivamente ai bambini.
E io e mio fratello
eravamo risultati vincitori
di un improbabile
carnevale estivo.
Io, vestita da hawaiana,
con il foulard di mia zia,
e mio fratello da samurai,
con la camicia di mio cugino.
L'animatore,
per premiarci, ci ha invitato
e si è rivolto a me con l'amorevolezza
con cui ci si rivolge
normalmente ai bambini.
E mi ha chiesto:
"Di dove sei?"
"Di Roma", gli ho risposto io
molto candidamente,
suscitando la sua ilarità
e di tutti quelli presenti
all'interno del campeggio,
che partecipavano a questa iniziativa.
Allora, lui, addolcendo il tono di voce,
come se da quello
dipendesse la mia risposta,
ci riprova,
e mi dice:
"Sì, certo, ma da DOVE vieni?"
Eravamo in Toscana, ricordate?
Per cui io, sempre più candidamente:
"DA Roma".
Lui sorride e ci riprova
una terza volta.
Ma non capisce.
E neanch'io lo capisco.
Ecco, ho voluto iniziare
da un aneddoto per parlarvi
di una delle sfide più importanti
che ci consegna la globalizzazione:
la convivenza.
Negli ultimi anni,
io mi sono occupata di accogliere,
orientare e informare
un gran numero di ragazzi
provenienti prevalentemente
dal Corno d'Africa.
E, anche, di sensibilizzare
i miei attuali concittadini
ai temi dell'immigrazione.
Milanesi di origine,
di adozione come me,
e di passaggio.
Ecco, anche quell'esperienza
mi ha aiutato
a comprendere che le immagini
che vengono utilizzate
per raccontare oggi, e anche ieri,
i fenomeni migratori,
non ci aiutano a proiettarci nel futuro.
Per questo voglio fare
un esperimento insieme a voi.
Proviamo a chiudere gli occhi.
Quando pensate all'immigrazione, oggi,
quali immagini vi vengono in mente?
Ci sono immagini più ricorrenti di altre?
Vedete delle persone?
Riuscite a distinguere i volti
di quelle persone?
A comprendere che ciascuna di loro
ha delle attitudini personali?
Riuscite a comprendere le loro
storie individuali?
A comprendere che possono
avere bisogni differenti?
Aprite gli occhi.
Erano barche, tende, muri,
fili spinati, masse indistinte di persone?
Ecco, quelle immagini
schiacciano il nostro sguardo
su un eterno presente,
uguale a se stesso da decenni.
Ed è per questo
che non utilizzerò immagini oggi
ma solamente parole
per raccontarvi la mia idea.
Le parole, qualcuno diceva
che erano importanti.
E utilizzerò le parole
per provare a costruire insieme a voi
un nuovo immaginario.
Sono convinta
che chiunque di voi abbia avuto
la possibilità di viaggiare,
visitare altre città,
sa come riconoscere un luogo accogliente.
Non solo per il grado di simpatia
dei cittadini,
ma anche, e soprattutto,
grazie all'accessibilità
dei servizi e delle informazioni
disponibili in città.
Accessibilità che passa anche attraverso
l'utilizzo di una lingua
di uso comune.
Ecco, comprendere le informazioni
e poter così accedere ai servizi
rappresenta il primo passo
per un progressivo
processo di integrazione
e di inclusione sociale.
Per iniziare a sentirsi parte,
soprattutto nelle città,
perché è nelle città
che gran parte degli immigrati,
quando ha la possibilità di scegliere,
risiede, preferisce risiedere.
Perchè è nelle città che possono trovare
lo spazio fisico e sociale
per accedere più facilmente
alle reti di sostegno,
sia dei connazionali che degli autoctoni.
E avere così maggiori opportunità,
dalla formazione al lavoro.
Ed è per questo
che bisogna partire dalle città.
Gli spazi, innanzitutto.
Gli spazi pubblici.
Perché gli spazi pubblici?
Perché sono preziosi, sono diffusi,
sono disponibili, sono accessibili,
sono gratuiti.
Spesso sono anche belli e accoglienti
pensate ai parchi urbani
o ad alcune piazze,
e rappresentano
la possibilità dell'incontro, per molti.
Soprattutto le persone
che vivono in periferia,
generalmente più poveri,
spesso immigrati
e ancora più spesso richiedenti asilo.
Ecco, immaginate una strada,
una strada in cui
il passaggio è molto frequente.
Potrebbe essere dotata di segnaletica,
una comunissima segnaletica stradale,
oppure di display digitali,
dei più evoluti display digitali,
in cui è possibile accedere
a tutte le informazioni
di cui si ha bisogno
per muoversi in città.
In più lingue, soprattutto.
Gli spazi pubblici,
i parchi urbani e le piazze,
potrebbero essere tutti
dotati di rete wi-fi
in modo che tutti possano avere sempre
la possibilità di accedere
alle informazioni.
E tutti, non solo gli emigrati.
Immaginate un quartiere,
un quartiere che è caratterizzato
dalla presenza
di una pluralità di culture.
Potrebbe dotarsi
di operatori transculturali
che facilitino la comunicazione
tra i residenti.
Tutti i residenti: quelli di oggi,
quelli di ieri, quelli di domani.
E immaginate che le istituzioni pubbliche
attivino campagne di ascolto periodiche
attraverso cui monitorano la qualità
delle relazioni tra le persone
attraverso appositi questionari
che aiutino anche al dialogo,
al confronto.
Immaginate che i luoghi di aggregazione
comunemente utilizzati dagli emigrati
possano diventare spazi sociali aperti
dedicati all'incontro
e alla conoscenza reciproca.
Oppure, pensate che alcuni spazi,
alcuni edifici abbandonati
possano diventare la sede
di associazioni di immigrati
o di associazioni
che si occupano di immigrazione.
Che esistono, nelle nostre città.
In questo modo possono
essere riconoscibili
e possono garantire, a tutti,
un livello di maggiore serenità,
perché io sono convinta che
quando vedete una ventina di persone
la domenica entrare in una chiesa,
voi siete sereni.
E siete sereni del fatto,
che quelle persone vanno a pregare.
Se voi vedete cinque volte al giorno
venti, trenta persone
entrare in uno scantinato
e non sapete quello che fanno,
non siete sicuri.
Se sapete che esiste un luogo
in cui quelle persone
possono andare a pregare,
voi siete più sicuri.
E anche le persone che vanno a pregare
possono essere più sicure e serene.
Ecco, questo perché?
Perché esistono
determinate caratteristiche
del vivere insieme.
La condivisione, l'aggregazione,
la possibilità di riconoscersi,
la possibilità di convivere.
Sono tutti termini che declinano
il concetto di cittadinanza.
E anche se è lo Stato che determina
le regole per l'accesso alla cittadinanza,
le città e le istituzioni locali possono
avere un ruolo determinante
per attivare i processi
di partecipazione attiva
di tutti i cittadini,
inclusi anche gli immigrati.
Vi faccio un esempio
di partecipazione attiva.
Un altro piccolo aneddoto.
Esiste un quartiere a Milano,
che ha suscitato da sempre
la mia curiosità.
Porta Venezia,
che, oltre ad essere uno dei luoghi
raccontati anche nei Promessi Sposi,
è conosciuto
come il quartiere africano di Milano.
Ebbene, nel 2013,
il confine a sud del Mediterraneo
si era spostato nelle strade
di quel quartiere.
All'inizio,
quando sono arrivati
i primi gruppi di migranti dal sud Italia,
un pezzo del quartiere è diventato
una centrale operativa di primo soccorso
in cui era disponibile tutto:
dai vestiti al cibo, ai medicinali.
Ed era tutto gestito
da immigrati eritrei e etiopici
che erano arrivati prima,
venti, trenta, quarant'anni [fa]
e che da quegli anni lì risiedevano
o avevano attività economiche.
Nel momento in cui le persone
sono diventate 300, 400
quest'equilibrio ha un po' vacillato.
E, soprattutto, le difficoltà,
che generavano un numero così grande
di persone nelle strade.
Perché li fate venire qui?
Questo è un quartiere residenziale,
non è un campo profughi.
Voi ci guadagnate qualche cosa.
Ecco, io non lo so,
chi ci guadagni meno o di più.
Però so una cosa:
che la domanda
che mi interessa pormi è un'altra
ed è la domanda
che vorrei porre anche a voi:
come possiamo guadagnarci tutti?
Senza perdere la capacità di distinguere
e senza perdere la capacità
di dare valore alla solidarietà.
Ecco,
secondo me, l'esempio di Porta Venezia
racconta di una risorsa,
di una risorsa in termini relazionali
che spesso è contenuta esclusivamente
nelle dinamiche delle comunità straniere.
Ecco, la qualità di quelle risorse,
potrebbe diventare patrimonio comune,
[potrebbe] essere integrata
in un sistema di accoglienza
che coinvolga tutta la città.
In modo che questo coinvolgimento,
questa partecipazione riconosciuta
possa attivare processi
di reinvenzione dell'identità.
Perché le identità
sono in continuo mutamento.
E poi, un'altra cosa,
un'altra piccola cosa.
Giusto per ...
... per portare una riflessione
su un'altra risorsa.
Voi sapete quanto vale,
in termini di ricchezza,
il lavoro degli stranieri, oggi in Italia?
127 miliardi,
secondo l'ultimo rapporto
della Fondazione Moressa.
E le rimesse?
Secondo Banca Italia,
le rimesse negli ultimi 10 anni
hanno più che raddoppiato
il valore della finanziaria del 2016:
64 miliardi.
Ecco, immaginate
che quel sentimento
che spinge le persone alla condivisione,
l'appartenenza,
possa essere il motore
per cui si istituiscano
anche strumenti finanziari.
Non so, proviamo a chiamarlo
"Fondo sociale di investimento urbano"
dedicato all'inclusione sociale
a compartecipazione mista.
Cittadini e istituzioni,
pubbliche e private.
Cittadini italiani e cittadini immigrati,
ovviamente.
Ecco, quello strumento,
insieme ad altri strumenti,
insieme o da soli,
in precisi contesti, diversi.
Vi dicevo: la segnaletica,
la tecnologia per la comunicazione,
gli operatori transculturali,
spazi dedicati,
campagne di ascolto,
fondi per l'investimento sociale
nelle città.
Quegli strumenti possono rappresentare
le risorse per costruire la convivenza
e forse, così, possiamo guadagnarci tutti.
(Applausi)